hi it's Matthew Martin from details and
we just finished the Versace show here
in Milan and it was bold and pumped up
for me it was all about the beautiful
overcoats and the gorgeous suiting the
suit through their double-breasted or
single-breasted and whether they were
patterned plaid or printed they each had
a really great proportion all of the
coats were super masculine whether they
were in fur or they were in just a
traditional cashmere or even in a great
like silky Busan there was one that was
quilted it was in that typical Versace
baroque pattern that i thought was
excellent and you know wouldn't be a
Prasad show without some whimsy and i
love that Donna tell that made lace
underwear for guys why should girls have
all the fun you know the thing I love
about the versace collection always is
that it's a hyper masculine collection
and it's for guys who are bold and not
what you know afraid to take some risks
however the thing about this entire show
is that there were so many great pieces
that you know literally every guy I know
and I know a lot of different guys
there's something in there for everyone
for more videos from Milan please check
out details calm and also you can follow
me on instagram and twitter at details
match